he needs to go completely none of this
nonsense about clinging on for a few
months he's inflicted lies fraud and
chaos in the country and you know we're
stuck with a function of the government
which isn't functioning in the middle of
a cost of living crisis and all of those
that have been propping him up should be
utterly ashamed of themselves we've had
12 years of a stagnant economy 12 years
of broken public services 12 years of
empty promises
enough is enough and the change we need
is not a change at the top of the tory
party it's much more fundamental than
that we need a change of government and
a fresh start for britain it doesn't
look like you'll get a general election
if
he just swaps leaders
he needs to go he can't cling on in this
way his own party have finally concluded
that he's unfit to be prime minister
they can't now inflicting on the country
for the next few months it's obvious
he's unfit to be prime minister that's
been blindingly obvious for a very very
long time and if they don't get rid of
him then labour will step up in the
national interest and bring a vote of no
confidence because we can't go on with
this prime minister clinging on for
months and months to come
wouldn't that unite the conservative
party
i don't think anything is going to unite
this conservative party they're tearing
each other apart and what we've got in
the middle of a cost of living crisis is
a government that can't function and
that's why i say he can't cling on now
they've declared him unfit to be prime
minister they can't inflict him on the
country for the next few months if they
don't get rid of him we will bring that
vote of no confidence
in the national interest because we
can't go on with this broken government
led by this discredited prime minister
boris johnson in some ways was your
biggest asset if you were going to go to
the country when you lose him you will
have more of a problem won't you look
the conservative party has been in power
for 12 years 12 years of a stagnant
economy 12 years of broken public
services 12 years of empty promises
we need a fresh start and that's why i
say changing the person at the top of
the conservative party is not the
fundamental change that we need we need
a change of government we need a fresh
start for our country
but it doesn't look like you will get
the general election you would want now
does it well we need fundamental
countries crying out for change we've
been stuck with a government that's not
been functioning in the middle of a cost
of living crisis
and now changing the person at the top
of the conservative party is not going
to make any difference whatsoever people
want change a fresh start for britain
and that means we need a change of
government we need a labor government
is there nobody
that you would rate as a good opponent
someone will be in against you for me
this isn't a question about who leads
the conservative party is much more
fundamental
than that they've been in power for 12
years
of empty promises broken promises a
stagnant economy wages very very low
inflation and prices through the roof we
need fundamental change we need a fresh
start for britain we need a change of
government we need a labor government
lastly i just want to ask you
given what you say about the government
you haven't cut through as you might
want to how can you do something about
that now we've come from
a general election in 2019 when we did
very badly to local elections this year
where we made considerable ground and
when a by-election win two weeks ago
today in wakefield with a huge swing to
the labour party so we're on track and
that's why we say the change we need is
a change of government a labor
government we're ready for that
thank you mr stammer